binomial theorem well binomial
expansions right all we're talking about
is these guys
binomials as in things with two terms
right you raise it to some power and
expand
hence expansions right so things like
that and then you see what you get at
the end
okay now one of the things i sort of
alluded to
i mentioned it like in passing reference
but i didn't explain it at all
was that it has to do with this pascal's
triangle
okay um and so by extension
um all of the ncr notation
also has to do with pascal's triangle
and i
to be honest i didn't understand this
until university so
i don't know if that means that i just
wasn't paying attention or that it was
just too hard for me to get
um when i was you know my year 12 brand
just wasn't sufficient
to understand these concepts but i'm
going to give it a go see if we can
explain that okay
i'm going to start back where i started
last time which is
thinking about what the binomials are
and thinking about well okay why do
their coefficients
lead us toward this thing okay what
what's the relationship right
so i've already sort of shown you that
um i've already sort of established
these results
so now i'm going to try and connect into
a pascal's triangle okay and then we're
going to rewrite all the passive
triangle in terms of
your ncr notation right uh a plus b
this basic binomial if we raise it to
the power of one
i'm actually going to do it out in rows
unusual rows
to try and make this connection a bit
more obvious okay so i'm going to get an
a and then i'm going to get a b and i'm
going to treat them as two separate ones
okay and my coefficient for each each of
these terms obviously
is just one and one okay now what does
that correspond to we'll just
just have pascal's triangle sort of
sitting in the back of your head as we
go on
all right let's raise the power so you
go to the power of two
now what i know in advance right is that
when i take these i'm gonna get um aas
or abs and bb so on that kind of thing
right
so can i get from here i want to build
this expansion of these terms okay so
for instance the first thing i would
write down
is i'm going to collect like terms for a
squared a squared
so that's two a's in a row now when i
look at these two
right i can only build two a's in a row
off this one right i'm going to take
that one
and add an a on the front that'll give
me 2 8.
okay now for my next row my a b
row b a row i want to get one of each
letter
okay so you can see i can build one off
here
by putting a b on the end okay
and then i can build one up here by
putting an a on the end okay so these
are my two terms which have different
letters right and then when i want to
get my ones which have two b's
again i can only build off here you
can't get two v's if you start with an a
i'm going to start with a b and add
another one
okay so can you see what i'm trying to
do here
one that coefficient we would normally
have written this as two a b
right and then this one has one okay now
the important thing to get is that
where do i get these two from i built
them off
each of these i needed one from here and
one from here and that's how i got two
all right let's go again when you raise
the power up one more time
okay well the first thing i want to
write down is how many a cubes
am i going to get right well if i want
to build three a's
okay you look at all four of these terms
which one can i use
well the only one i can get three a's
off is this one
right so i take that and i add one more
a okay i can't get three a's out of any
more of these terms
all right my next one is a squared
b so i want two a's and one b okay how
many of those can i get
well you can see that i can get a two
a's and one b
from any one of these terms except this
one can you see that once i've got this
i can't get two ways in there because
they're all gonna have three terms
so i can go this one this one or this
one i can build
let's see here um put a b on the end of
this one
so i've got two a's in one b put an a
on the end of this one you get a b
a and then put a on the end of this one
as well so i get
b a a so these are all the terms i could
possibly build which have two a's and
one b
right and i'm done i got that that row
right i got it by looking at all three
of these terms i had to take those two
and then i add them up all right what
about
two b's and one a how many possible ways
can i build that right
well i can build two b's and one a
off of every term except for that one
right because i can't fit two b's in
there because then i'm gonna have
four letters right so if i go these
three here
right i want two b's and one a so if i
take this one
and add a b on the end right
take this one and add a b on the end and
then
take this one i don't want to add a b on
the end because that'll make it three
b's right
so i'll add an a on the end
okay so here are my three turns two b's
and one a so normally i write a b square
and then lastly of course i've got
my three b's and there's only one way
only one of these
can lead me into a triple b right
so can you see right let me try and draw
some arrows here to draw the connections
i've got one term here
three terms here three and one right
where did these three terms come from it
came from taking these two rows
and every term in them and modifying
them in some way
right so that's how i got three i got
this three in a similar way
i took these two rows here right
okay let's do it one more time and then
hopefully that'll be enough and you'll
probably run out of space
anyway let's raise it to the power four
okay
all right now can you see the way i'm
building this
if i'm raising to the power of four all
of these
words as a word that i'm going to get at
the end they're all going to be four
characters just like these or three
characters two characters
one character okay so i want to make one
with four
eight well out of all of these there's
only one i can possibly use
namely this one right so that's why i'm
just going to have
one of him okay now i want how many can
i build
where i've got three a's and one b
or can you see which ones i'm gonna use
right i'm gonna use i can get three a's
and one b out of that
and i can get three a's and one b out of
all of these terms okay
so here how do i get that i'll add a b
on the end
right and then for these ones i'm going
to add
an a on the end i'll get a a b a
a b a a
b a
and that's all i can do there's no other
way i can get three a's and a b
right so i use these two rows to build
up this one
right and you can repeat the same
exercise for how can i get
um oh sorry no see this is where i get a
new row
so now i've got three a's and a b now i
think about how many ways can i get
two a's and two b's two a's in two b
now have a look at these two rows up
here right i cannot get two a's and two
b's out of here
right because i've already got three a's
can't get two a's and two b's out of
here
it's already got three b's but i can get
two a's and two b's
off any of these six right you just have
to add a
different letter each time so in this
case right what would i add on the end i
guess i would add
a b on the end that'll give me two a's
and two b's
here um i'll add a b on the end again
and then this one i'll add a b on the
end okay
so i've got two ways and two b's off all
of these
and here of this next row how do i get
two a's and two b's up here
well i guess i'll add a on the end of
every single term
right so this is gonna be
a popular european band uh
one of my favorite elephant cartoons
from the past almost
and whatever that is okay so i added b
look at the end of all of them okay so
you can see that
yeah sorry did i miss one oh yeah sorry
thanks
a's and b's they all look like i should
put different letters hanging okay
uh so three a's gonna be
two a's two b's the next one is gonna be
three b's and an a so you can actually
just take this one
and swap all the b's with a's
okay three a's and a b and then this one
of course at the end will be
four b's all right now when you do your
count
okay you've got your one four six
four one and the key to understand is
well where did those numbers come from
like where did that six come from
the six came from the fact that every
one of these terms
is built off of these two rows
right oh that's a terrible brace let's
try that again
that's better okay
these three and these three right turn
into this
is six okay so can you see why
now let's let's write down the actual
coefficients how would we normally write
this expansion
we would ordinarily write
uh a plus b that's no problem here we'd
write a
squared plus two a b plus b squared here
we'd write a cubed plus three
a squared b plus three a b squared plus
b
cubed and one more for good measure n to
the four
four a cubed b
six a squared b squared
four a b cubed and
b to the fourth okay so you can see
these coefficients here they line up
with pascal's triangle
because solving this problem is the same
as the way we build pascal's triangle
right which is you do oh i add these two
numbers and you get three
right so when you've got this kind of
structure
even though you think of them as well
this one i just get from straight
you know edition right and this comes
from algebra
well the algebra comes from the same
rules of addition
right
all right now remember i said that this
expansion idea
right i connected it to this right
so now i'm connecting the expansion idea
to this
right pascal's triangle so therefore
i can rewrite pascal's triangle just in
terms of
ncr notation okay so
how does it work
use this color okay um think about
say this expansion here okay now what
did we learn about binomial theorem i
asked you to write it in general form do
you remember have you got it there
where you've got like a plus b to the
power of
n okay and your coefficients in all your
different terms okay
what's the first coefficient do you
remember zero
that's right n true zero okay and then
you've got just
a to the n and you have no lots of b
and then the next one will be n choose
one okay and then you've got one less
lot of a
and one more line of b and so on right
okay so how can we use that here well
think about say this row here
one two one okay where it came from was
this expansion
so it's going to be that one is really
to choose not right this two
is really to choose one and then two
choose two
along the end okay it just has one row
so i can write the whole lot in the same
way
if this is these are all twos right the
next row up will be one choose
naught and one choose one okay
at the top you've got naught choose not
we know i've got no things and i want to
choose none of them there's only
one way right and every other row can
also be built using nci
notation in exactly the same way three
one
three two three three
okay and so on right so you
this is a really important part it's
identified explicitly in the program
that you've got to get how this and
these
and this all connect to each other okay
um they're kind of like i was going to
say two sides of the same coin but it's
three sides
so and you can't make it geometric well
actually a coin kind of has
it's like that it's the rim of the coin
if it was a bitcoin
anyway